In this level, we set up Android Studio
which was a big operation.
Then we learned a bit about
the Git version control system and
downloaded the course code from GitHub.
Then we learned about the structure of
a libGDX project and about the Gradle
build tool that actually compiles and
packages the games we'll build.
Then we imported our first libGDX
project into Android Studio and
set up a new run configuration
to launch the desktop backend.
Next, we launched the Android backend.
Finally, we made a small
tweak to the game and
got some more practice launching
the desktop and Android backends.
That was a lot of work.
Awesome job taking care of all
the setup and background work.
Next level is all about drawing.
We'll start with some basic shapes and
work up to some crazy fractals.
See you there.